j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
il porte sur un monstre sacré de
l'histoire de la peinture Pablo Picasso
Morelia 50 ans mais l'année 2023 doit
être l'année Picasso plusieurs voix
s'élève pour rappeler que justement
c'était un monstre surtout pour les
femmes qu'il n'aimaient plus et qu'il
faut le désacraliser peut-on séparer
l'homme de l'artiste jusqu'où doit aller
la contextualisation des œuvres passées
avant d'en débattre Audrey Vittaz nous
explique pourquoi le maître espagnol
fait polémique
un portrait géant hommage à Pablo
Picasso dans un champ de 25000 m² en
Italie l'image résume à elle seule
l'influence que l'artiste a encore 50
ans après sa mort c'est l'un des plus
grands peintres du 20e siècle avec le
cubisme il a changé notre rapport au
corps
un des plus grands peintres qui n'est
jamais existé un homme formidable un
artiste formidable pardon un homme c'est
différent différent car derrière le
génie se cache un homme que l'on décrit
comme tyrannique superstitieux égoïste
il y a quelques années Sophie Chauveau
se lance dans une biographie de
l'artiste qu'elle adulte elle découvre
un monstre un minotaure avec les femmes
notamment son insati a besoin d'amour et
d'attachement s'exprime de manière
tantôt affectueuse tantôt cruelle
d'abord il les aime ensuite il les casse
exemple avec Olga coqlova l'une de ses
épouses qui aime la finesse et déteste
le cubisme il l'a peint d'abord sublime
au début de leur relation vraiment des
portraits du 19e siècle très très bien
fini et après il va il va la détruire et
ça la détruit elle
parce que elle est très classique elle a
un gourus soient bien finies je suis pas
sûr que femme de sa vie ou même ensemble
ou même ami c'était un sort en viable
pendant trois ans Sophie Chauveau relie
les ouvrages les interviews et se rend
compte que tout a été écrit mais que
personne n'a rien voulu voir face à un
Picasso riche admiré célèbre François
Gilot justement quand il emmène que des
Grands Augustins dans son atelier
il lui dit là là haut je vous enfermerai
je vous montrais à manger puis vous
serez qu'à moi plus personne vous verrez
il la connait à peine ils sont pas
encore une histoire d'amour ils lui dis
ça il y a eu des choses épouvantables il
adopte un enfant avec Fernand et puis on
va le rendre à l'orphelinat enfin vous
imaginez il fait des choses
abracadabrant dans un esprit de j'ai
tous les droits et il a tous les droits
et on lui laisse tous les droits depuis
Mitou partout dans le monde les actions
se multiplient pour questionner
l'héritage de l'artiste comme ici à
Barcelone des étudiantes font face à ses
œuvres sur leur T-shirt on lit Picasso
Barbe-Bleue Picasso Marie violent
certains appellent même au boycott
Sophie Chauveau elle y est farouchement
opposé un jaillissement pareil c'est
inouï ça n'arrive pas souvent alors ne
pas y aller se priver nous priver tous
de ça mais qu'elle hésit au contraire
sachant qu'il est vraiment dans ses
coins sombres dans ce par maudite dans
tout ça
mais
admirons une œuvre c'est aussi le point
de vue du musée Picasso à Paris qui a
fait le choix de la pédagogie c'est
toute la difficulté du travail que nous
devons faire aujourd'hui c'est à dire à
la fois accueillir le débat accueillir
les les
critiques sur l'homme Picasso et son
rapport aux femmes et en même temps
rappeler qu'elles sont nos missions
essentielles qui est celle de préserver
un patrimoine ici c'est un patrimoine
picassien et d'arriver à lui faire
passer en fait la barre du 21e siècle
les expositions excessivement élogieuses
n'auront plus leur place les pardons de
Picasso seront désormais mise en lumière
séparer l'homme de l'artiste voilà l'une
des questions qu'on va se poser faut-il
boycotter Picasso le thème central de
notre débat j'accueille Brigitte
Benkemoun bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
écrivaine auteur de plusieurs livres sa
vie pour Picasso publié l'an dernier et
puis je suis le carnet de Rama aux
éditions stockent Ludivine gaillard
bonsoir bien vous êtes médiatisés
culturel auteur de ce livre imparfaits
représenté la femme dans l'art
occidental entre fantasmes et domination
masculine qui est publiée aux éditions
First Nathalie mondil bonsoir bienvenue
à vous aussi vous êtes directrice du
Musée des expositions de l'Institut du
monde arabe et vous avez
dirigé tes commissaires de plusieurs
expositions sur l'oeuvre de Pablo
Picasso Mathieu croissanto évidemment
est resté à mes côtés littoralistes
politiques on va commencer peut-être
Brigitte par la façon dont vous décrivez
Picasso dans vos livres il y a
évidemment le génie puis à l'homme à la
fois dominateur un phénomène d'emprise
peut-être un ogre on peut dire ça
vous dire ogre on peut dire monstre
d'égoïsme après il y a des mots qui
commencent à émerger aujourd'hui et
qu'il faut refuser on vous avait parlé
du du podcast Vénus et piletel la chatte
ou le montant que Picasso est un
prédateur sexuel prédateur sexuel c'est
quelqu'un qui fait du mal pour faire du
mal qui est cruel pour pour faire
souffrir c'est pas ça Picasso Picasso
c'est un monstre d'égoïsme c'est un
homme qui né à la fin du 19e siècle au
fin fond de l'Espagne donc il faut
s'interroger sur nos arrières grand-père
comment ils étaient comment ils se
comportaient avec nos arrières arrières
grand-mère et donc Picasso il a il a ça
dans la tête il est en plus un petit
garçon qui a été élevé par des femmes et
porter élevée comme un comme un génie
comme un génie qui va devenir donc c'est
un égoïste c'est un monstre d'égoïsme
c'est un ogre mais au service de son
œuvre les femmes
moi c'est ce que j'ai fini par
comprendre en dépassant les premières
réactions qu'on peut avoir quand on lit
certaines choses
il dévore au service de son œuvre donc
il croise par exemple Marie-Thérèse
devant la Galerie Lafayette elle
correspond à une certaine idée à
certains certaines esquisses qui
commencent à faire et elle va l'obséder
il veut absolument faire son portrait
devenir indispensable et il en a 45 donc
bon en effet il y a un décalage il y a
une raison peut-être de d'un ascendant
qui va avoir sur elle et elle lui
devient indispensable et il est fou
d'amour pour cette fille qui régénère
son œuvre qu'il aurait génère lui aussi
et quand il va devenir un peu moins
indispensable qu'une autre va passer et
qu'elle va elle-même susciter un nouveau
mouvement dans son oeuvre elle va être
quand il est amoureux en fait
par exemple en 1936
lui il crée pas quand il est malheureux
quand il est malheureux en 36 et qu'il
n'arrive plus à peindre il se met à la
peinture il se met à la à la poésie une
poésie un petit peu difficile d'accès
mais il a besoin d'être dans le
l'euphorie et l'amour la passion pour
pour avoir envie de créer de se lancer
de nouveaux défis gaillard est-ce qu'on
peut il y a aussi une question dans ce
débat c'est est-ce que ça peut être la
ni Picasso est-ce qu'on peut célébrer
les 50 ans de la disparition de de
Picasso en faisant abstraction de ce
qu'on vient de décrire dans le sujet ou
avec Brigitte Beth kenoud cette c'est
violence psychologique physique aussi
sur sur les femmes qui étaient dans sa
vie je pense qu'il est difficile de
faire abstraction aujourd'hui avec tous
les écrits qui ont pu sortir à ce sujet
mais que comme vous le dites justement
Brigitte il est important aussi de
contextualiser à chaque fois et
aussi je pense que on met souvent les
mêmes artistes sur le devant là donc
certes c'est le 59 de sa mort mais il
est aussi important de penser à aux
artistes femmes aussi à mettre davantage
en avant pour ce genre d'événements et
voilà mais en tout cas oui pour tout ce
qui est le côté voilà
ogre de Picasso comment on disait je
pense qu'on peut plus faire l'impasse de
sucre c'est important de parler de ses
relations aux autres et pas seulement
une grande partie du public peut-être
des téléspectateurs étaient les
spectateurs qui nous regardent qui
connaissent pas forcément cette
dimension du personnage donc quand on en
a parlé autour de nous et qu'on a évoqué
le fait d'organiser des bail on avait on
voulait le titrer Picasso était-il un
[__] mais et puis il y a une non mais
pourquoi pas on aurait pu comme ça voilà
je suis en transparent sur le sur les
coulisses de la fabrication de
l'émission il y a pas mal de gens qu'on
a croisé qui me disaient mais bon
c'était un [__] donc il y a un devoir
quoi de d'informations aussi c'est ce
que c'est ce que vous nous dites
pourtant ça fait quand même quelques
décennies que Picasso est montré comme
ça mais peut-être oui effectivement le
grand public
peut-être une partie ne connaît pas
encore ce côté là est-ce que c'est parce
qu'on l'a gommé Nathalie Bondil cette
dimension de Picasso pendant plusieurs
décennies certaines façons ou ou c'était
pas dans voilà dans les dans les dans
l'air du temps ou dans les
préoccupations de de du grand public et
des organisateurs d'exposition il y a 10
ou 20 ans oui je pense que c'est très
juste en fait
autre temps outremeers et l'oeuvre de
Picasso a toujours
été reconnu pour ce qu'elle était
ensuite donc le regard que nous portons
sur l'oeuvre changent suivant les
époques que nous traversons
l'histoire partir de l'art est
impermanente notre regard est
impermanent il évolue
évidemment donc maintenant le regard que
l'on pose sur l'oeuvre de Picasso et sur
l'homme qui a fait l'oeuvre est un
regard qui est
contextualisé par une époque où on veut
redonner de la visibilité aux femmes où
on veut donc rééquilibrer donc les
relations de domination homme-femme ou
effectivement on a de nouveaux filtres
donc pour relire donc cette oeuvre là je
dirais pas que c'est une censure qui
était opérée auparavant c'est davantage
donc une évolution de notre regard et
j'imagine que dans 10 ans ou 20 ans on
saura encore regarder cette œuvre
différemment la femme qui pleure enfin
les femmes qui pleurent qui attendent
des femmes battues est-ce que c'est
est-ce qu'on a une complètement
il y a des choses à dire parce qu'on
entend beaucoup de choses oui la femme
qui pleure c'est dorama et il la peinte
alors il y a deux il y a deux versions
c'est
soit pour représenter la souffrance de
l'Espagne au moment de la guerre
d'Espagne soit parce que comme ils le
disait aussi à Malraux le Dora Marc lui
a toujours évoqué cette femme qui me
preneur c'est une femme kafkaïenne une
femme tourmentée et puis je dois dire
que dorama elle-même a dit que la femme
qui pleure n'était pas elle en fait dans
le l'émission que nous venons de voir
donc il y a aussi des faussetés c'est
d'où l'intérêt dans le reportage vous
voulez qu'on vient de dire dans les
propos de certains des des certaines
personnes qu'on interviewer dire que
Picasso a pu donc faire des violences
physiques dans le sens donc premier du
terme donc si vous parlez
la difficulté de ce genre de de projet
ou on va avoir
c'est plutôt dans le podcast dans dans
vous parliez tout à fait tout à l'heure
exactement
le sujet qu'on a diffusé dans un dans la
biographie que Pierre cabanes a consacré
à Picasso et qui lui dit littéralement
moi les bras m'en sont tombés parce que
c'est quelqu'un de sérieux pire cabanes
des plus grands historiens d'art de du
20e siècle et il dit que Picasso quand
il est à Royan un jour il a battu Dora
mars si fort que il l'a laissé au sol et
tout ça sans dire d'où il le tient sans
dire quelle est sa source et tout le
monde pouvait le lire il y a eu des
choses terribles aussi dans une
interview que marie-thérèsa corde à ce
même pierre cabanes sur mais je pense
que les gens écoutaient ça lisez ça et
il n'y c'est pas une grande importance
c'est assez dingue mais c'est vrai alors
est-ce que c'est une modifications
c'est une vie très longue il est en 1881
donc il me rendit à 173 il a eu
plusieurs compagnes qu'il a beaucoup
aimé et les relations qu'il a pu avoir
entre Fernand Olivier donc durant sa
jeunesse ils avaient le même âge
exactement ils étaient dans la vingtaine
donc ne sont pas du tout les mêmes que
les relations qu'il pourra avoir ensuite
quand ils vieillira avec Jacqueline rox
sa dernière compagne qui l'appelait
Monseigneur il faut comprendre que il y
a eu une évolution dans les relations de
Pablo Picasso avec ses compagnes au
moment où c'était un jeune artiste donc
très peu
aller à au début de sa reconnaissance et
de sa notoriété avec très peu de moyens
à l'époque de Fernand d'Olivier par
exemple
ils sont à Montmartre au bateau Lavoie
et ensuite donc il y a eu un décalage
qui s'est opéré au fur et à mesure de
l'ascension professionnelle du peintre
au fur et à mesure aussi de la est-ce
qu'il y a des époques oui d'être aussi
vieux basique dans mes questions
peut-être en fait voilà donc il y a donc
deux phrases il y a des mots comme ça
mais après quand on lit donc les les
récits là je en fait j'ai amené ce livre
de Laurence Madeline qui est une très
très grande experte de Picasso qui
s'appelle Picasso huit femmes qui a fait
des recherches très précises sur dans
les archives donc en fait le but c'est
de pouvoir contextualiser donc la vie
d'une personne
depuis ses premières relations avec des
femmes jusqu'à la fin où il était devenu
tellement un monument un personnage
quand Françoise Gillot donc rencontre
Picasso elle veut le rencontrer donc
elle se elle va son atelier avec une
jeune peintre une étudiante elle est
fascinée par par le personnage on
imagine mal la notoriété que Picasso
pouvait avoir à l'époque ça n'excuse pas
d'éventuelles comportements d'emprise en
Suisse ou de je sais pas de
séquestration on a entendu ce mot-là
tout à l'heure où est-ce que je veux
dire le génie n'est ou la notoriété
n'excuse rien rien ne le justifie mais
par contre donc entre le fait de
catégoriser avec donc un qualificatif
donc très réducteur donc un homme un
moment de sa vie donc comme un prédateur
sexuel donc en fait quand on compare
avec d'autres artistes ou d'autres mœurs
de l'époque et bien les les
comportements n'étaient pas pareillement
acceptés de ce que ce qu'on veut
simplement dire ici et pourtant je suis
extrêmement engagée sur ces questions
donc depuis très longtemps c'est que le
contexte est très important pour pouvoir
essayer d'avoir une assez complexe de
pas être binaire dans dans le jugement
Mathieu où il est intervenir la
contextualisation pardon mais c'est
aussi souvent la défense des hommes
coupables de violences sexuelles ou
sexistes et c'est pas de ma faute
j'étais très énervé ou c'est pas de ma
faute je l'aimais beaucoup ou c'est
typiquement le premier réflexe et on
contextualise c'est soit en considère
qu'il y a un acte de violence soit on
considère qu'il y en a pas et avec
Divine gaillard on rajoute je repose la
question du enfin plus plus l'artiste et
et génial plus la notoriété plus on peut
demander peut-être tendance à l'excuser
est-ce que vous ressentez ça
oui d'abord je voulais rebondir ce que
vous disiez Françoise Gillot a pu dire
dans des interviews que Picasso
qualifiait les femmes de machines à
souffrir voir les comparades et
paillassons
ça donne quand même une déjà une idée de
ce qui pouvait penser des femmes mais il
est vrai que on n'a pas de preuve
contrainte concrètes pardon de si oui ou
non il a battu ses compagnes mais on a
quand même des indices qui peuvent
laisser penser que il avait une façon de
ne serait-ce que de percevoir les femmes
qui étaient
c'est sexiste
peut-être violente après dans les gestes
moi non plus je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
vu de source à ce sujet là en fait de
recontexualiser et je reviens à cet
exemple de Fernand d'Olivier qui est une
aussi des rares avec Françoise Gilot à
avoir écrit en fait il y a deux
campagnes qui ont quitté Picasso et qui
ont écrit sur leur relation il s'agit de
Fernand d'Olivier de Françoise Gillot et
Fernand d'Olivier elle a été vraiment
victime de violence donc sexuelles elle
était violée elle s'est enfui d'un mari
qui est mort fou donc ça c'est avéré et
quand elle part de la relation qu'elle a
avec Picasso certes donc c'était
quelqu'un de jaloux je suis pas en train
de justifier mais il y a jamais question
de violence il y a toujours donc une
personne qui était attentive
attentionnée et
c'est c'est ce sont les les dires même
des personnes qui ont vécu avec lui
après la relation ce que je veux dire
c'est que cet homme a eu des relations
différentes avec les différentes
il y a deux de ses compagnes qui se sont
suicidés est-ce qu'il faut forcément
faire le lien entre l'emprise qu'on
prête à Picasso et
sur les violences physiques on peut dire
en effet on sait pas on sait pas parce
que Pierre cabanes a glissé comme ça une
phrase sur dorama Marie-Thérèse
elle-même répond à ce besoin Valter
répond à ce même pierre cabanes quand il
lui demande quelle est la définition du
bonheur selon Picasso elle dit bah il
viole d'abord la femme et après on
travaille donc il faut contextualiser ce
verbe violer mais ça veut dire dans tous
les cas que quand il décidait il
demandait pas son avis à la pauvre
Marie-Thérèse Walter donc c'est un homme
du 19e siècle qui grandit dans un siècle
où il a de plus en plus de poids de plus
en plus de pouvoir ou tout peu de gens
lui résistent et la femme est considérée
comme on l'a considéré à l'époque
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui doit qui doit
accepter qui doit céder qui doit servir
qui doit disparaître quand on lui
demande de disparaître et Picasso est
vraiment à cette image là donc
les violences elles sont probablement
pas physiques en tout cas
exceptionnellement et elles sont
essentiellement psychologiques
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
sur le le génie mais je vais la reposer
à tout le monde parce que je me sens
importante est-ce qu'on est plutôt
tolérant avec un artiste génial sur ces
il faut pas il faut que la société a été
que ce soit que ce soit pierre d'exp
pierre cabane
Richardson tous les grands biographes
des Picasso ont été en sachant tout ce
qu'il savait sur Picasso ont été d'une
immense indulgence pour lui parce qu'ils
étaient tous fascinés par lui et puis
parce qu'ils étaient des hommes et que
eux-mêmes avaient des schémas de pensée
par rapport à ces femmes qu'elles soient
artistes ou pas parce que Françoise
Gilou est une artiste Dora marie est une
artiste et elles sont elles reviennent
et ça c'est extrêmement juste donc
raconter contextualiser ce n'est pas
justifié ni légitimer donc quand on
parle par exemple de Gisèle et limi donc
une très grande figure que je cite donc
la reconnaissance même du viol donc
c'est le procès de Bobigny donc c'est
quand même donc dans les années 70
il faut aussi se remettre dans ce
contexte là où c'est pas simplement un
homme qui soit génial ou qu'il ne soit
pas mais que c'était une société qui
j'entends très bien cet argument donc ce
genre de de comportement inadmissible
envers les femmes ou envers la parole
Mathieu pardon nous interrompre j'essaie
de le faire le moins possible mais il y
a plein de questions qui qui me viennent
et je voudrais quand même reparler de la
votre métier de commissaire d'expo
est-ce que quand vous dites j'ai Picasso
c'est quand même une chance inouïe pour
amuser est-ce que je j'étends vous
pouvez avoir tendance à gommer
sombre d'un génie quand on quand on
lance une exposition vous voyez ce que
je veux dire absolument pas donc je
crois que le but c'est même il y a 20
ans je peux aujourd'hui je pense que
l'action
c'est une question très intéressante
parce qu'il m'a été donné de travailler
plusieurs fois donc sur Picasso au cours
de ma vie bon là j'ai 55 ans donc quand
j'avais travaillé sur l'expédition
Picasso érotique en l'an 2000 et à
l'époque c'était avec Jean-Jacques Lebel
qui cocheval et bon moi j'étais
commissaire adjointe et c'est un projet
qui maintenant évidemment ne pourrait
plus se faire parce que donc il y avait
c'était un un projet qui justement
exalté donc la virilité donc de l'homme
qui serait aussi prodigieuse que ça
prodigalité artistique
c'était une exposition extrêmement
intéressante par ailleurs mais c'est
évident qu'un projet comme celui-ci qui
a été présenté que ce soit Barcel à
Paris ou à Montréal donc maintenant ne
pourrait plus être
commissariat de la même façon
là j'ai travaillé très récemment sur une
un projet sur Fernand d'Olivier
justement et qui inversait complètement
donc la perspective donc pour faire
parler la femme la compagne parce qu'il
y avait jamais eu d'expositions qui lui
avait été consacré tout simplement et je
crois qu'il est très juste de remettre
les pendules à l'heure et de pouvoir
inverser les perspectives pour donner la
parole justement à à ses compagnes qui
elle aussi ont des choses à dire et
qu'on a certainement pas assez entendu
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être ça
l'exposition qu'il faut faire maintenant
c'est à dire une exposition sur les qui
met en valeur les les femmes de Picasso
oui ça c'est un verserait un petit peu
la tendance puisqu'on les a pas on a pas
assez vu de se positionner monographique
sur elle je sais même pas si on a eu en
France sur Françoise Gillot non mais en
fait chacune oui
il y a eu des expositions sauf sur
Fernand mais il y a eu plusieurs
expositions
montre qu'on gomme toujours les aspects
d'un génie ce qu'il faut séparer l'homme
de l'artiste est-ce que vous dites
est-ce qu'il faut séparer l'homme de
l'artisan est-ce qu'il faut on dit
est-ce qu'il faut séparer du politique
bien évidemment non bien au contraire
même Picasso lui-même
que l'oeuvre qu'on fait une façon de
tenir un jour son journal donc lui-même
son oeuvre
que pour les artistes
de Blanche Gardin
César mais
puis on est en pleine affaire pour le
ski elle dit elle dit est-ce qu'on dit
ah ben ce boulanger elles sont pas était
vraiment tellement bon il était génial
bon d'accord et ils se comportait mal
avec les petits enfants mais enfin
qu'est-ce que son père bah non on on dit
jamais ça d'un boulanger ou un plombier
voilà c'est c'est un peu cette
démonstration là bon on va sortir un peu
du sol des bas Picasso pour parce que ça
ouvre évidemment plein de questions sur
effectivement la place des artistes
notre regard qui change sur sur les
artistes on va parler littérature
maintenant et notamment des grands
classiques de la littérature avec
Jonathan du prière rebond soit Jonathan
faut-il les réécrire des bas relancer
récemment à propos d'une autrice célèbre
oui il s'agit d'Agatha Christie un qu'on
connaît tous ici et ces fameuses
enquêtes d'Hercule Poirot le détective
belge et bien elles seront bientôt plus
tout à fait les mêmes l'éditeur français
de la reine du crime qui s'appelle les
éditions du Masque bien connu annoncé la
réécriture de certains passages de ces
romans c'est polars iconique a écrit
entre les années 20 et 1975 certains
passages jugés blessants offensant ou
racistes et bien ils vont être amenés à
disparaître et vous allez le voir je
vais prendre un exemple d'un titre
célèbre Mort sur le Nil qui est paru en
1945 dans sa version française et bien
exit le passage sur je cite les naisses
plus petits égyptiens ou le terme
indigène qui sera remplacé par le terme
local et Agatha Christie c'est pas la
seule à avoir connu ce type de révision
de son œuvre on a parlé de Yann Fleming
notamment et aussi de rôle dalles dans
Charlie chocolaterie par exemple qu'on
connaît tous aussi et ben il y a des
passages qui ont été censurés parce que
jugé discriminant voire grossophobe ou
en tout cas aussi discriminant en termes
de santé mentale ou pourquoi pas sur les
préjugés ratios là aussi réécrire les
classiques tendances qui provient
notamment du monde anglo-saxon c'est
même devenu un métier à part entière
dans l'édition oui c'est un métier est
devenu incontournable on les appelle les
Sand City readers avec l'accent le job
de sélecteurs d'un nouveau genre et bien
c'est de passer les livres au peigne fin
et de retoquer tout ce qui pourrait être
offensant pour les minorités ou qui
pourrait déclencher des polémiques dans
la société ou sur les réseaux sociaux
par exemple pour un roman de taille
moyenne et ben cette relecture elle va
coûter entre 1500 et 2000 euros dollars
mais qu'importe le du coup depuis trois
ans et la sortie de l'ouvrage que vous
allez voir s'afficher sur votre écran
qui s'appelle American dirt c'est
l'autrice Jenning kummings qu'il a
publié et bien l'édition
outre-Atlantique ne se passe plus de ses
sandcity Reader avant de publier un
livre pourquoi en quoi cette ouvrage
avait fait polémique aux États-Unis et
bien en soi pas grand chose sur le
papier le roman relate la fuite d'une
libraire mexicaine qui sous la menace de
cartel de la drogue se réfugier aux
États-Unis avec son fils alors voilà
rien de polémique sauf que la parution
de l'ouvrage tombe un peu dans un
mauvais timing aux États-Unis en plein
débat sur l'appropriation culturelle et
il se trouve qu'en fait Jenning kummings
l'Autriche c'est bien elle est
américaine née en Espagne et donc elle
se retrouve tout à coup dans un dans un
tourbillon où on l'accuse de simplifier
la question de l'immigration
latino-américaine d'exploiter la
souffrance des émigrés et de caricaturer
aussi le Mexique donc vous l'aurez
compris alors le roman c'est très bien
vendu tout de même il faut quand même le
préciser on est on voit bien voilà les
enjeux de ce type de de réécriture de
c'est finalement un débat un peu sans
fin sur est-ce que on y voit un retour
en force d'une certaine forme de censure
au contraire finalement un progrès et
est-ce qu'on va pas vers quelque chose
qui qui permet à l'édition et notamment
de sensibiliser sur de nouvelles
questions merci beaucoup pour pour
toutes ces explications je voudrais
juste dire que American Burt de Janine
coming c'est un magnifique roman est
plus fort que j'ai vu de ces cinq
dernières années avis totalement
personnelle mais et d'ailleurs ça
commence par une scène elle est elle est
mariée à un journaliste qui est tué par
un cartel il y a deux mois je lis une
dépêche AFP qui raconte l'histoire d'un
journaliste qui vient d'être tué par un
cartel au Mexique bon bref c'est une des
réalités de ce pays qu'il faut
certainement pas gommer même si ce n'est
pas la seule réalité du Mexique j'en
suis conscient qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ces sensitivity Reader je commence
avec vous Brigitte ma réaction c'est me
dire on est entre attention on est en
train de rogner la créativité les
auteurs quoi
la créativité des auteurs quand on
soumet un manuscrit à l'avocat de son
éditeur donc en gros l'éditeur se couvre
d'éventuelles attaques en faisant lire
le manuscrit à quelqu'un qui a un autre
point de vue que l'avocat et moi mon
dernier livre sur Marie-Thérèse Walter a
été relu par le l'avocat des éditions
Stock je n'y ai pas vu un mais là c'est
autre chose parce que
vous êtes romancier vous créez un
personnage
ultra raciste dans votre roman si on a
un sens je dis voilà c'est un personnage
et on a un sensibilisation
et moi par exemple un moment donné on
m'a demandé de retirer la phrase que
Marie-Thérèse allaitait sa Fille parce
que on portait atteinte à la vie privée
de Maya donc j'ai refusé de retirer
cette phrase en plus j'ai trouvé le
tableau où on la voit en train
d'allaiter sa fille donc on avait la
preuve mais on va déjà très loin avec
les avocats vous savez votre avis n'a
été immondile parce que vous avez
longtemps travaillé au Canada
et vous êtes canadienne je n'avais pas
cette information donc tout ça illogique
vous étiez
directrice du Musée des Beaux-Arts c'est
ça de Montréal c'est quand même une
tendance qui nous vient de du monde
anglo-saxon est-ce que on est en retard
en France sur ces questions là parce que
c'est ce que disait Jonathan est-ce que
c'est une forme de censure ou est-ce que
c'est une forme de progrès pour vous
en fait je dirais
dit l'un ni l'autre c'est un
élargissement de nos visions qui dépend
des lieux ou des cultures dont on parle
donc j'ai essayé toute une pensée de
déconstruction donc qui vient de la
French théorie au départ de et qui vise
effectivement à substituer des
vérités par des récits donc de pouvoir
mettre de l'avant aussi des
subjectivités des interprétations des
relativités des décentracrements par
rapport à des discours qui sont
dominants donc ils sont hégémoniques
dans le fond c'est un exercice
extrêmement sain je trouve que c'est un
exercice démocratique aussi c'est de
pouvoir
porter la polyphonie la pluralité la
diversité des perspectives là où ça
devient peut-être plus problématique
c'est quand ce discours qui se veut
inclusif donc devient exclusif et se
pose comme un discours essentialiste ou
alors
à chaque fois ça tombe sur vous mais
c'est vraiment pas volontaire et ou
alors il faut que je sois mexicain pour
écrire sur le l'immigration mexicaine
pardon mais c'est tellement réducteur
c'est c'est la problématique et donc
pour revenir aussi à cette question de
censure et de liberté de la parole donc
quand on relie des textes d'Agatha
Christie de rwandael évidemment donc les
textes ils ont été écrits donc comme les
œuvres de Picasso ont été faites dans
certaines époques donc les relires donc
les édités on dirait donc des
contextualiser et absolument
indispensable après donc censuré c'est
autre chose et d'ailleurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour Gwendal donc
les l'éditeur finalement donc avec la
famille on a refusé donc qui est
l'interdiction de publier les récits
originaux et pour moi la question de
fond c'est vraiment une question de
liberté de débat démocratique c'est à
dire que
avoir et élargir donc les perspectives
donc amener donc des points de vue
militants des points de vue activistes
des points de vue engagés je trouve ça
extraordinaire c'est très important
c'est fondamental donc pouvoir justement
aller sur la voie du progrès comme vous
disiez pour ne plus accepter des
comportements qui auraient pu l'être les
curseurs ont changé notre époque a
changé et ça va continuer mais ensuite
ce qui est
là où il faut faire attention c'est
qu'un discours ne se substitue pas à un
autre pour moi c'est l'un et l'autre
c'est un élargissement des voies et
cette complexité donc elle appartient de
fond aller au débat démocratique une
démocratie c'est pouvoir discuter
entendre des voix qui ne sont pas les
mêmes que les nôtres et pouvoir inventer
ensemble une dessinée commune et en ce
moment donc ce que l'on entend beaucoup
c'est un discours qui est aussi donc qui
peut-être parfois outrancier je ne veux
pas dire qu'il le soit toujours c'est
pour ça que et à la censure la censure
n'apporte rien la censure n'explique pas
il vaut mieux de la contexte culture
alors on va avancer dans ce débat avec
d'autres exemples pour des allant parler
de d'artistes enfin pas pour americander
mais Agatha Christie oualda des artistes
qui ne sont plus de ce monde mais pour
des artistes vivants et condamnés pour
des faits de violence peuvent-ils
reprendre leur carrière après avoir
purgé leur peine évidemment la question
elle se pose pour Bertrand Cantat joue
propose d'entendre le témoignage de
Lorraine question qui est une militante
féministe du Conseil national pour le
droit des femmes c'est lors d'un
rassemblement devant le Zénith Bertrand
Cantat il donne un concert on l'écoute
on est dans une société où il y a une
culture du viol une culture de la
violence une culture patriarcale qui est
extrêmement ancrée et c'est pour ça que
pour nous c'est absolument pas anodin
qu'une personne qui a tué sa conjointe
par 30 coups de poing ou coup en tout
cas puisse retourner sur scène comme si
de rien n'était qu'il reprenait sa
carrière et qui l'utilisait un ensemble
de on va dire de concept pour
pratiquement se faire passer pour une
victime
j'ai posé une question pardon un peu
binaire mais Ludivine gaillard est-ce
qu'il faut interdire à Bertrand Cantat
de chanter
déjà il faudrait qu'il soit condamné je
sais plus s'il a purgé il a purgé sa
peine mais ce qui m'embête dans ce genre
d'histoire c'est que le problème en
compte je pense d'ailleurs à apollens
qui qui a reçu le César de meilleure
réalisateur
avec toutes ces histoires de viol et de
pédocrinalité qui l'avait derrière lui
je pense que c'est c'est important
d'arrêter de d'encenser ou de mettre en
avant ce genre de personne qui ont été
condamnés qui a été condamné qu'à 43
jours de prison parce que ça envoie un
mauvais signal
ça envoie un mauvais signal d'une part
aux victimes des victimes de ces
personnes là mais aussi des victimes
comme vous et moi plus lambda on va dire
que leur agresseur peut continuer à
faire sa vie à être
commencer à voir son public etc et ça
aussi ça
il a purgé sa peine il a été condamné il
a purgé sa peine et ce qu'il a le droit
de continuer ce qu'il peut refaire son
métier enfin bon voilà c'est
pour reprendre moi je pense que ça peut
être la liberté de chacun d'aller voir
ou pas après moi
d'y aller ou de ne pas y aller mais ça
ça envoie aussi un message
moi je suis plus sur paulinski parce
qu'il a reçu un prix ça envoie un
message aussi au potentiel agresseur de
voir cette impunité aussi comme ça on
peut reprendre l'exemple du boulanger
tout à l'heure le boulanger s'il fait 50
prisons il peut reprendre sa boulangerie
donc après on voit bien qu'on n'est pas
un problème on n'est pas face à un
problème de droit mais pas un problème
moral donc d'Oxy Bertrand compta veut
remonter sur scène c'est son droit ça
peut être le nôtre ça peut être le nôtre
de pas aller le voir et de pas applaudir
et je pense que c'est la limite elle
doit se déterminer comme ça pour
paulanski comme pour Quentin votre avis
peut-être sur Bertrand Cantat
assister à un concert de Bertrand Cantat
d'ailleurs il avait voulu donc
il y avait du chanter à Montréal avec
moi Jim Wade qui est un immense auteur
de théâtre donc qui a fait des pièces
extraordinaires et qui l'avait invité et
il y a eu un tel débat que le le Théâtre
du Nouveau Monde a annulé à prestation
de Bertrand Cantat alors effectivement
on s'est dit oui il a perdu il a pu
purger sa peine mais ensuite donc il y
avait quand même là on parle d'un film
d'ici enfin je veux dire c'est c'est là
on est plus dans le viol l'agression là
c'est c'est c'est un meurtre et
malheureusement donc Nadine Trintignant
elle est plus là pour pour en parler
c'est toujours la problématique des
victimes qui vivent avec leur souffrance
avec donc toute leur vie ou parfois qui
ne vivent plus tout simplement
après bon est-ce à nous donc de nous
porter
juge du droit il y a des systèmes qui
existent peut-être qu'ils ne sont pas
opérants encore une fois je reviens à la
question du viol et à Gisèle à la limite
à énormément travailler sur cette
question le viol dans un contexte
conjugal en France donc n'a été pénalisé
que dans les années 90 90 alors qu'en
fait c'est le lieu le lit conjugal et
quand même le lieu où ce genre de de
méfait et de violence se fait le plus
donc il faut nous sommes en 23 c'était
en 90
c'est là où j'amène beaucoup d'humilité
aussi par rapport à nos jugements parce
que effectivement ces relectures elles
sont absolument nécessaires
mais en même temps nos parents nos
grands-parents ont probablement essayé
de faire du mieux qu'il pouvait eux
aussi comme nous et non probablement pas
tout vu et j'imagine que nos enfants et
nos petits enfants nous apprendront
beaucoup de choses à leur tour
[Musique]
Marie Trintignant excusez-moi bien sûr
on va vous l'avez évoqué parler aussi de
romans de Polanski dans ce dans ce débat
alors ça pose la question effectivement
est-ce qu'on va voir son film au cinéma
parce que en allant voir son film au
cinéma on peut considérer qu'on finance
son œuvre alors qu'on sait ce qui s'est
passé dans dans sa vie en tout cas c'est
l'argument qui était porté là aussi par
une représentante d'une association
cohema des stats qui organisé une action
blocage en étant novembre 2019 avant
première parisienne du film j'accuse on
appelle complètement au boycott
aujourd'hui acheter une place de cinéma
c'est pas un geste anodin ça finance
littéralement la prise de parole de des
réalisateurs et en plus ça leur donne
une légitimité dans leur visibilité à
être entendu dans l'espace public donc
oui c'est un geste qu'on considère comme
comme criminel même si il s'agit
initialement seulement d'acheter un
ticket mais c'est pas que ça en fait
Ludivine gaillard cet argument il vous
semble important faites de ne pas
financer finalement le cinéma de
Polanski en avance si on est en accord
avec ce qu'on a dit et qu'on condamne ce
genre de violence de méfaits je pense
qu'il est important en tant que personne
de se positionner par rapport à ça en
cas individuel parce que avant que ce
soit l'artiste qui donc Polanski le
cinéaste qui va être rémunéré c'est
aussi l'homme en tant que tel celui qui
a commis ses crimes et donc je pense que
c'est assez essentiel de marquer le coup
si on est convaincu de du fait qu'on ne
doit pas lui rendre ce service entre
guillemets enfin aller dans son sens
quelque part pour moi c'est cautionner
de faire ça de
même si sa victime a retiré sa plainte
j'ai pas tous les détails de l'affaire
Polanski mais je sais qu'il y a enfin
j'ai lu qu'il y avait plusieurs victimes
si je dis pas de qui s'est exprimée
effectivement juste avant la sortie de
j'accuse dans une interview à Paris
Match et d'ailleurs je parle beaucoup de
moi donc je suis vraiment désolé mais
c'est ce qui moi m'a bloqué dans l'idée
d'aller voir le film en salle je suis
pas allé le voir en salle pour cette
raison parce que c'était moyen je m'a
ému touché et donc voilà c'est venu en
plus de la première affaire qui datait
de l'époque américaine donc
effectivement il y a ces deux affaires
là le fait que la première victime de
Polanski est retiré sa plainte Brigitte
Kemoun est-ce que pour vous ça ça influe
dans la décision de spectatrice d'aller
voir un film de toute façon c'est ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure pour moi
c'est une question morale et on comprend
bien pourquoi elle l'a retiré sa plainte
on comprend bien aussi pourquoi cette
gamine quand elle a 13 ans et qu'elle se
retrouve chez Polanski c'est sa mère qui
l'a poussé dans les bras de Polanski il
y a quelque chose d'assez sordide dans
tout ça de bout en bout donc quel tirer
sa plainte pour des raisons qui nous
échappent franchement ça change rien
mais après moi je me demande je me
demande où on s'arrête c'est à dire que
paulanski a été condamné
Bertrand Cantat était condamné mais
Woody Allen qu'est-ce qu'on fait
franchement moi je vois pas je vois pas
pourquoi on n'irait pas voir les films
Woody Allen et pourtant il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ne vont plus voir les films
Audi Allen et là il y a toute une
polémique qui démarre autour de deux
Part-Dieu alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
va plus voir les films de Depardieu non
plus je posais des questions je vous
avoue que j'ai pas forcément les
réponses se trouve une réponse et n'est
parfois cohérent et voilà on n'est pas
cohérent sur toute la la durée de notre
propre histoire Nathalie Bondy est-ce
que Paulhan est-ce que la France est
perçue et je reviens à votre expérience
nord-américaine comme une sorte de de
terre d'accueil pour un point romane
Polanski est-ce que dans ça a été
présenté
comme comme ça depuis plusieurs années
c'est sûr que les poursuites concernant
ce cas donc proviennent des États-Unis
donc et d'une législation qui est
différente de celle française après moi
je ne suis pas un tribunal public je ne
suis pas avocate ni procureur
je lis comme vous donc dans les médias
je ne suis pas une spécialiste de ce cas
je crois que l'attitude que vous dites
c'est-à-dire on vote avec son
portefeuille quelque part donc mais pour
tout je veux dire sur pour soutenir la
consommation bio comme pour soutenir les
artistes qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
et je crois que là pour le coup quand on
fait ses choix ce sont des choix
démocratiques ce sont des choix
personnels et qu'on peut s'exprimer et
de ce point de vue là ça ça me convient
on est dans un rapport qui est moral la
question légale et et très différente
quand on est en Amérique du Nord il y a
des sensibilités des problématiques qui
sont beaucoup plus fortes quand qu'en
France pour des raisons culturelles des
questions historiques et inversement et
quand vous irez dans le monde arabe et
bien vous allez vous trouver avec
d'autres types de de valeurs de priorité
c'est aussi d'amener cette cette
humilité par rapport à ces différentes
perspectives qui amènent nos jugements
à être
infléchi nuancée
toujours pour cette raison que je
reviens à cette complexité qui est
nécessaire
le discours anglo-saxon en ce moment est
extrêmement fort c'est un discours comme
il l'a toujours été et on l'entend parce
que les vocables même pour
parler de wokies de cancel coltcher etc
donc procède des
d'Amérique du Nord il y a des valeurs
que nous allons défendre qui sont
importantes dans un contexte républicain
français comme universalisme ou la
laïcité et je parle de ça mais qui ne
sont pas entendables qui ne sont pas
audibles quand vous êtes en Amérique du
Nord et pourtant donc nous sommes dans
des cultures et des référents différents
c'est pour ça que l'expérience que j'ai
pu avoir au Québec a été très
intéressante parce qu'on était vraiment
constamment entre ces deux Confluences
philosophiques si je puis dire entre
l'Amérique du Nord et le courant
anglophone et puis évidemment le courant
francophone européen et français merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat Brigitte Benkemoun je
rappelle le titre de vos livres sa vie
pour Picasso
l'histoire de Marie-Thérèse Walter dont
on a parlé et puis je suis le carnet de
Dora Marie de son publié aux édition
stocking gaillard imparfait représentait
la femme dans la occidentale c'est
publié chez First merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité je vous dis à
mardi prochain Mathieu je vous explique
les clés de l'émission pour pour demain
vous serez là demain évidemment 18h et
22h sur Public Sénat et puis vous pouvez
retrouver nos émissions celle-ci et tous
les programmes de la chaîne en replay
sur notre site notre plateforme public
sénat.fr demain prochain rendez-vous
politique c'est Bruno retaillod le
président du groupe LR au Sénat qui sera
l'invité Dorian Mancini belle soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]